[Music]
there is a lot out there to be afraid of
right now
and um
a lot of different people's buttons are
being pushed in different ways
on all these all this economic news and
the truth is that fear
is not
a good decision-making tool
panic is an even worse decision-making
tool
and it's when you do the dumbest things
when you are functioning in fear your
les your lizard brain kicks in and your
critical thinking skills disappear
your critical thinking skills return
when you pan back and you keep
perspective and what gives you the
ability to do that is knowledge
the more you know about something the
more the game slows down
and you can play
and it seems like you're in the matrix
and you can just dodge the bullets right
yeah and you don't fall for all the
traps out there when you're a calm level
header you're not doing the 401k loan
and the heloc and buy now pay later
because you know better now it's just
you know when you
how many times have i talked to somebody
over the years including myself in the
mirror and the dumbest things i've ever
done or right after i got desperate and
scared
i mean that's just before you get really
stupid you're scared
just before you get really stupid you're
desperate
and the one the king will keep you from
doing that and reacting
to all the news instead of making a
decision because here's the thing
i mean let's use the bear market as an
example okay then bear the bear is here
okay the definition of a bear market's a
20 drop
and the stock market's down more than 20
it's probably down 21 today total since
the first year okay
now what does that mean
have you lost everything no
it means if you had a hundred thousand
dollars and you were retired you already
didn't have enough
and instead of 100 you have 80.
if you had a million dollars and you
retired
instead of a million you have 800
really doesn't affect your life much
it really doesn't
but it affects your emotions a lot
and here's the other thing the app
there's been 14 bear markets
since world war ii wow
okay
the average length of a bear market is
13 months
the average recovery time is 24 months
two years
okay
so when will it be back to where it was
in january
on average two years
and that's happened 14 times
and you lived through them all since
world war ii
yep i didn't live through all of them
but i lived through several of them yeah
thank you george but that wasn't an ace
joke i did not mean to go there no but
it happened too late you just stumbled
right into it but yeah tell us about the
40s but the uh yeah tell us about the
50s and the 40s
that was a twinkle in my daddy's eye but
what you're trying to say is perspective
helps
so yeah there you go for a lot of us
this might be the first one we're
experiencing
it does give because that's the thing if
you're um
you know if you're in your 20s
um
this is the first economic downturn for
you as an adult
because 2008 you were a baby child
okay so this is your first one
and so if you're 26 and you're freaking
out
it's because it's your first car wreck
i've had several car wrecks and so now i
just get out and we exchange licenses
and call the cops
as long as nobody's hurt we're okay
right
and so you know but the first time you
have one it's like oh god yeah you're
ready
you know right
and it's it's it's traumatic so but when
when tragedy or trauma or
uh
something comes at you and it activates
fear it shuts your brain's ability down
to do critical thinking skills so let's
pretend the market's down 20 the big bad
bears out okay now the bear is here and
what are we gonna do with the bear okay
now here think about it all right if the
average there's 14 of them that's a
pretty good data set and the average is
24 months back
so where are you going to be in 24
months
24 months older
even if you're 68 you'll just be 70.
if you're 24 you're gonna be 26 and it's
gonna be back
so your 100 your 80 will be 100 again
your 800 will be a million again
that's the average and what will it be
five years from now
it'll be way up five years from now
these are the averages
so when you pan back and you go okay
when it drops it generally comes back
like has every time
a hundred percent of the time it is
recovered
all the time it's always gone up from
there so if you're looking at if you're
26 and you're looking out there to 66
you're not really worried about what it
does until you get out there
and there's no time in history that it's
gone more than five years without making
money zero except the great depression
and this is not the great depression
there's some great stupidity going on in
washington but it's not the great
depression it's different
and so just way different it's a
completely different set of facts and
data and processes
and yet people's get their emotions
kicked in and here's what's very
interesting to me george like we posted
this thing on instagram about what was
happening with housing oh yeah you know
all the haters that blew up yeah all the
haters come out so you went viral but um
yeah i i i
i am well anyway but the uh
things i do so whatever use your filter
not since covet but yeah um
but anyway the uh uh
the when people that are intellectual
become afraid
it's very interesting that the
way their stupidity manifests is
intellectually
they come up with these bizarre
layered arguments to prove that the
world is coming to an end because their
emotions have already decided that the
world is coming to an end instead of
panning back and actually being calm and
looking at the data and looking at the
historical
precedents that are there and keeping
perspective when they're doing this if
you pan back and do all that you just
your little butt calms down
that's what it amounts to because if in
perspective you know what's going on and
that makes all the difference in the
world you find whatever you're looking
for and if you look at the data and go
well the world is coming to an end
it might be for you in your mind and you
will intellectually fight for your right
to be
to be right about the world coming to an
end and you'll bring everyone down with
you around you real fun at parties and
you know here's the horrible thing is it
makes you a commenter
on instagram which is the lowest form of
life when you what about twitter you
didn't even have something to say you
had to comment on something someone else
said i mean this is like you've really
hit bottom honey when you are when the
only thing you have to do is to comment
on instagram you truly have they think
that's the only thing in their control
is that how many times i have commented
on instagram zero no no once i no i said
pretty baby
nice dog oh wow was that on my instagram
stuff like that no you don't have a baby
you have a nice dog thank you but yeah
but the i mean great little frenchies
you're saying you've only commented
positive things well i mean it's more
like you know my friend's got his little
kid out there water skiing and i'm like
that's awesome because your mama taught
you got nothing nice to say don't say
nothing at all don't comment but i'm not
gonna get in there and argue with some
dupe i don't even know with no username
be wrong in the comments section it's so
embarrassing i wouldn't want to do that
bless y'all's heart
seriously leave that to me dave i'll
handle the comment section
[Applause]
okay that's what the block button was
invented for today
just for you this is the ramsey show